c'est un virus baptisé h3n2 identifiait
fin décembre chez nous à ce jour un cas
grave a été signalé et hospitalisés en
réanimation et de virus grippaux ont été
isolés au chu de martinique
l'agencé régionale de santé parle d'un
début de circulation virale elle a
constaté une augmentation du nombre de
personnes touchées pendant la première
semaine de janvier
environ 450 cas via le réseau des
médecins sentinelles et sos médecins
le soir on a le nez qui coule ça coule
de l'eau on ne sait pas pourquoi et puis
on a froid et puis un petit peu mal à la
gorge et puis après ça continue ça
s'arrête pas le médecin vous dit le
médecin m'a dit que c'est une grippe
mais c'est allergiques donc ça a été
importé donc c'est tout le monde c'est
vrai qu'on a une forte demande pour des
maux de gorge donc tout ce qui est
pastique auditoire d tout souvent tout
grâce état grippal le nez qui coule mal
à la tête des courbatures enfin tous les
symptômes sont sont bel et bien là oui
la population est invitée à être
vigilante et chacun y va de ses conseils
c'est assez brutal je suis j'ai dû aller
aux jo
en fait c'était la grippe que j'avais
depuis cette année j'ai pris le vaste et
coûtera cette année le vaccin 6
on peut la voir bon parce que bon
quelquefois c'est en rupture puis après
bon il ya quand même des petits remèdes
qu'on peut prévoir soit par
l'homéopathie autre chose et voilà faire
du thé de campagne le titre campagne
c'est ce qui permet au cerveau de se
dégager fait avec toutes sortes de thé
de campagne en effusion barbouillé vous
avez d'abord la toux maux vous avez de
lebron vous avez la moindre glacial vous
avez la mode de l'année on privilégie
tout ce qui est gelée royale vitamines
bien sûr se laver les mains plus souvent
possible éviter d'être en contact avec
avec des personnes grippées
en effet pour limiter la propagation du
virus les bons gestes sont à adopter se
laver les mains se couvrir le nez et la
bouche se moucher dans un mouchoir à
usage unique éviter de se toucher le
visage et quand on est déjà malade
rester chez soi l'élite et la sortie
contacter le médecin si besoin
limiter les contacts et porter un masque
notamment au contact des personnes
fragiles